for 30 years i've been teaching people  how to become wealthy and i got to tell  you what's going on out there right now  i'm kind of sad and i'm a little bit  angry  i'm seeing get rich quick  everywhere it has exploded  let me tell you the only people getting  rich quick on get rich quick schemes are  the jokers selling you the stuff to do  it it's completely out of control  listen 30 years of data 30 years of  walking through and showing people how  to become wealthy tens of thousands of  millionaires because of what we've  taught them tell us that the way you  build wealth is slow and steady time and  consistency that's how you become  wealthy don't fall for the jokers trying  to sell you stuff on get rich quick